welcome back to the morning toast we are
so excited for the first time in eight
months
to have breathing living human beings in
our studio and of course it is friend of
the toast
simon huck and launching his new podcast
with his co-host melissa gray washington
a little hyphen
we love a hyphen hi hello
we're so excited to be here thank you
for being here this is so exciting for
us
it feels really good and the studio is
so glam simon has got the old studio
which
everyone knows we were evicted big drama
but now we're here and we're it's simon
approved
no it's very glam high ceilings simon
approved that's all about great lighting
yeah great lighting so last time you
were here you were owner of you know
entrepreneur of a fabulous fabulous
company and now you are coming to us
as a podcaster yes you have lowered your
bar
joined us here in the podcast world no
it's really very high low no
so i started this company judy which is
an emergency preparedness brand
everyone knows everyone knows okay so
2020 has been kind of this outrageous
year
so many emergencies and melissa has been
my real life ride or die emergency
contact and we wanted to do
a podcast but we didn't really know how
to talk about emergencies and also make
it something that people wanted to
listen to
how do you two know each other oh my god
so we met like 400 years ago in college
we were introduced by a mutual friend
simon you went to college he's shocking
barely believe me where did you guys go
we're canadian
so we went to this girl called queens no
michael everyone thank you everyone
yeah everybody which is like queens has
such bad branding because mcgill is like
chic the queens is like the harvard of
the north
no not even mcgraw
honestly i had morgan stewart on my mind
right so this is like canada in a
nutshell like what's in it
um anyway so we went to college together
and we met through a mutual friend and
we just like
instantly fell in love and then he
hasn't been able to shake me since and i
was her maid of honor in her first
wedding i hooked her
i hooked her up with her first husband
who was my roommate in college oh wow
yeah yes yes so she's like thanks for
bringing that no she's always like can
you stop bringing that up but i'm like
it is their reason it's the the genesis
of our relationship you're right you
know what you're right it's a pretty
like key part of the story
yeah so then yeah we moved to new york
together around the same time i moved
before psy
and then he moved like a few months
later well and melissa was studying
public relations and at the time i was
like oh my god i love sex in the city
i want to be like my only like everyone
else like everyone else i was like kim
katrel's character like
how do i do that you did it but i didn't
know what pr was
and so melissa's like oh no pr is not
real like you don't need to go to school
for
it trust me i'm in school right like i'm
yes i'm in school
actually like unfortunately for pr and
melissa i think you worked for like a
travel pr company
yeah it was it was not like glam let me
put it that way
and then i like picked up the telephone
and called lizzie gruben's office
and got this free internship and at the
time jonathan chevin
now now known as the food god um
don't disrespect him and use his no i
know how do you know
i know when i say john he's like excuse
me and i'm like
i don't know are you well no the food
goddess
is his first name food last name god
soup to be like food
or food full food god no you cannot say
food
right so no first in life
um no he's so not well but i like in the
best way i love him
um anyway so that was kind of the
genesis
of our beginning of our relationship and
then we wanted to do a podcast on kind
of judy and emergency preparedness but
we couldn't think of an
interesting fun way to do it and then we
thought wait a minute what if we tried
to find
the relationship that we have in
celebrities like who is
khloe kardashian's real life ride or die
emergency country in that case it's well
known yeah
yeah but in many other cases it's not
really well known like
like kim and allison totally prime
exactly that's a great
example and like people who like are
there real like there's so many
instagram friendships like you see
like celebrities post it's like love you
boo but like do you love them like do
you even know each other
do you even know each other yeah we'll
be the judge of that right so the
concept is basically bringing on
well-known people and like who is in
their close personal circles who was
there quote-unquote emergency contact
exactly and we want to know what they
were like
like kind of their pre-glow up yes of
course they're pre-fame
yeah and we've had such interesting
guests we have your first episode is
already out right yes
with tan france and his husband who were
just
incredible i mean tan is like the most
humble sweetest
funniest human being alive and his
husband i had not really spent a lot of
time with i mean was he not just
no he i mean i don't want to he might
even be he might i might like him better
than tan yeah
i love everybody loves tan fans right
like world's nicest but the hus
his husband rob was so funny so normal
so unaffected so disinterested
in like fame love i don't know it was
great
and brought ten at a retirement first of
all 10 retired at 35 which i was like
okay
goals and he didn't want to do queer eye
and rob was like no no you have to give
this a chance like it
could be a really big opportunity and
thank god he did it because we wouldn't
have tan right now
right we have rob to thank and so
logistically you guys
you live in philadelphia so you guys are
podcasting via zoom which is very common
in the age of corona
how are you adjusting i know you've done
reality tv who could forget the spin
crowd
a um of people have forgotten it
unfortunately
i'll never forget thank you you've
conquered the world of reality tv you've
conquered the world of pr you've
conquered the world of entrepreneurship
now you've got to get into podcasting
which is actually not as easy as people
think like
audio is really [ __ ] hard like
beyonce okay all you have to do is
listen to one episode of our show to get
that yeah
i cannot get my audience if you need
advice you could always come down it's
actually a lot of work like people just
think you like press record and suddenly
no no there's like
briefing talks like melissa discovered
what a google doc was she had not heard
of a google doc before and like you die
no i know it was great my life free
google docs was great but now i just
like i can never find it i don't know
like
am i looking at it is someone else i
agree i don't want anyone messing with
my edits like i want to send you a word
document like it's 19.99
and have you send it back to me in green
or red or like color track
changes yeah totally track changes
google docs i'm just like sigh it just
scares me i was like it's a living
breathing document she's like excuse me
it's like it's alive where is it
he's like i don't know it's like in
google somewhere like where do i go
he's like get on gmail i want to go off
track really quickly and just point out
melissa that you were sitting with your
purse which i just love like
oh my god queen elizabeth should i have
left it at the door no it's still sorry
i don't know it's just like an
interesting way to sit
down what am i doing wrong oh my god
this is like my first rodeo
should i have like i should have left at
the door but you know what it's here now
no i love that you're a beautiful person
okay when you have a beautiful purse you
should show it up as much as oh my god i
just love that you're just like sitting
with it and it is like very prepared of
you so i wouldn't want
to contact you like i have an rx yeah in
here
she's actually and i'm dying to ask you
guys this she is the least prepared
person we do a quiz on our show
we ask like 20 questions melissa would
be like zero to zero like
could not save a soul dust yeah yeah
thank you
what are some of the questions how do we
know if we're scared like
what do you do in the event of a fire on
the upstairs floor of your home
grab my phone and take the elevator
precisely
precisely no really grab theo and run
down the stairs right like just like
basic preparedness information that most
people don't know like before judy i was
i was the worst judy i didn't even know
where my fire extinguisher was and god
forbid i had to use it
yeah i don't know okay and you just like
dump things that like you know your
instincts kick in and all of a sudden
you know how to use it right that's what
you rely on
does every apartment have a fire
extinguisher every floor
so they recommend that every floor so
like even if you have three floors
even in your basement you should have a
fire extinguisher in your home in your
home well some people even do every room
like oh those people yeah yeah yeah i
mean i don't want to
get no no yeah
so that's a lot yeah it's a lot so do
you feel like since starting the podcast
with simon you've become
more prepared like you were zero are you
maybe not like a two a little bit like i
could probably survive
24 hours whereas before i was just gonna
be like a goner
right right out of the gate like i
didn't know that in a fire i can't
remember we did like a fire quiz and
simon was like no you're actually going
to go up in flames i'm worried for you
like offline he was like well i want to
talk to you about your fire preparedness
plan
oh my god my plan is like nobody wait
for my husband just right like me and
the kids will find out stop drop and
roll everyone
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no i do feel i
feel because because i went from like a
net place of like
negative 10 on the knowledge scale i
feel pretty
good now and we do like franchises so
like we just did chloe and malika and we
did a tsunami franchise where we talked
about like
15 things you needed to know about
tsunamis and then quiz them on it and
like what do you need to know
honestly i didn't realize that the
united states like we actually had
tsunamis
that's the first point yeah the tsunamis
exist in the u.s yeah shocking
there's this place in california called
crescent city oh my god i hope that's
the name please don't come for me i
think it is
okay and they have had 33 tsunamis since
like
the 1940s wow yeah isn't that wild
that's terrible
yeah and just like learning about how to
prepare for them and okay so simon in
the age of coronavirus where we're all
kind of being prepared
on another level what are three things
nobody should leave their house without
you should leave their home or have them
have in your home
both okay inside your home you should
have food and water for up to 72 hours
okay you should have a first aid kit and
you should have an emergency plan and
the emergency plan is free
like you should know how do i exit out
of my apartment right
you know what is the do i have i check
my smoke detector my carbon monoxide
detector like basic
information where should we meet where
should we meet having in a meeting spot
also a communication strategy like if
you have kids who are of the age where
they have a cell phone like what do they
do when the wi-fi goes out or they lose
their
their cell service like so many people
in the event of emergencies they do this
thing called milling where they don't
believe that emergency is real like
if i knew a tsunami was coming or a fire
was coming wildfire was coming they
don't actually like
listen they wait and they're like did
you hear there's an evacuation warning
right
and jackie's like claudia i'm not going
until it like i hear from another person
and suddenly you're like
hello we told you to evacuate so
unbelievable some of the things that are
happening yeah this year
this year especially even with coped
like how many of us had conversations
with our friends were like this isn't
real
yeah like i don't think i'm taking it
that seriously well that's why we've
been loving this new season of the
kardashians because it's actually the
footage of like what people were saying
before coronavirus it's like
there's this thing called coronavirus
like should we go to paris it's like i
think we're going to be okay people are
saying stuff
right so it's like there was so much
uncertainty it's actually interesting to
watch like
how we took it before we knew it was
like a serious thing no and before
kim went to paris i was sitting with her
and i gave her a judy kit that had
kind of these wildfire prevention masks
we now know them as n95 but before this
uh judy we had no idea
we had never even thought about a
commodity yeah yeah right and she was
like i'm gonna use my mask on the plane
i'm like oh i think that's excessive
like you probably
don't need to fast forward now right
yeah it's like i think
we came in with a hazmat suit onto the
studio right yeah no it's crazy
crazy times yeah it really is the
podcast is available everywhere
yes everywhere amazon spotify yes
amazon just amazon just launched
podcasts yeah amazon music
spotify itunes stitcher public radio all
the places oh my god yes
that's very exciting and it's called
emergency contact
and you can follow both of them on
instagram catch up on new episodes find
out information
see simon without a shirt on great
picture by the way thank you face tune
face out everything all of you
love that thank you guys so much for
being here thank you guys for listening
and we'll see you tomorrow for her uh
nothing just tuesday oh no wednesday
hump day okay
you